chi è pronto per altre due vittorie così
poche piante credo però che mi piace di
ragazzi buona visione
manga non me la spiego è difficilmente
ed ilarità rifarla riff alla banca come
sia a personaggi lista gioco go dante
l'altro tu ma domani
stiamo cercando figure si chiama che
perdono sarkozy quando sarà il giorno
prima donna
andiamo alla vecchia in parte dai la
chat si sta incuriosendo esci del
segreto pagato già ragazzo mio dio scusa
che succede se guardo in un determinato
punto del gioco si paga tutto anche se
si paga what si paga il personaggio di
vento tipo uno di quei dinosauri ma te
lo giuro
ora può rifare
poi due ne manca uno dove magari come
elettrica tu cosa per terra
[Risate]
ce l'avevo già visto passare scaltro
come una volta niente sono della folle
aspiri tutto gravgaard allo pietro
incavolatissimo quali la finish era
questa dov'è andato a finire ma sento
che cammina mai fatto prima
qui servono a mayer genetici e non hanno
nemmeno hanno sentito gli spari dal
dalai
vediamo ora avevano davanti giocare
avanti
caricato vai sotto la casa su un succo
da casa quelli che gli spari di shot gun
da qua ci sono due timi sar
state molto attenti quella di ancora di
gara
colpito questo è ko e sotto sotto di te
colpito ma viene tagliato veneto sta
facendo giro sto facendo giro su di me
ma voglio iniziare in mezzo dice due
team che si combatte tutti in qualche si
combattano tutti i morti tutti i morti
non sei un altro ancora e quanti
similari scusami sei andato non capivo
se ritmo era il nemico credere abbiamo
fatto tre chili diverse sono morti chiti
sul polpo erano tre squadre ma quando
uno troppo a una cosa viola vuol dire
che c'è una gettoniera quando il gialle
leggendario è esatto dire che almeno c'è
quello del miglior di con il colore si
non ti fa perdere tempo le lusinghe
arrivo aia a gente che si impara a
sinistra beschi perché ciò però fa
veramente schifo una perdita ma quindi
voi non avete nulla da chi la testa non
lo sai ma scusami come fa quell'altro
essere kyi leader con trek il perché
ogni tanto lo si paga non l'ho mai
capito perché comunque si cerca vadim il
altro treno ma allora si cercano di
capire e non ci sono qua qua ci sono
armi qua destra palestre eccolo il fai
che scappando la mela giu
ma i 69 dietro
oggi mi sparano al codice arrivo io non
so che questa sparata noi dava la cosa
fa dove fa il mastino che insegue
proprio a lui l'ultimo team è l'ultimo
team quello no la sono ancora dei visti
la speranza di loro sono gli ultimi due
team che si sparo incidente dice gente
guardava solo visto che si è piena pieni
punti mandato mir insanabili con ii salì
qua dietro e ci facciamo da tommy pop là
fuori uno dei sciolto lo shopping 2 6 2
un aiuto
varetto cavolo questa è strano che non
ti abbia messo però chi leader nel
mentre una certa io avevo oltre kg detto
cavolo un killer a tre killer come
faccio il nostro sito dei sei online
donna teletrasporto figlia che sembra
davvero pazzo questa qui c'è il ragazzo
che è infedele e infatti incazzata ora
gli occhi poi è semplice per gli sporchi
non so se è un'impressione mia ovvero è
infatti c'è una skin in cui non ha i
capelli ha detto basta mi sono seccato
cose care si è tolto due invece duma un
low down è semplicemente uno youtube
perché noi che che voleva fare
che cosa pensi di fare di più per ma non
può trovare un lavoro normale e quindi
si è messo la maestra decordi perché non
sa che capitare che la società c'è gente
qua dove dove chiudo doping e dai raga
sanno che sanno che arriviamo quindi
ecco li madou norme anti proiettile non
dispera visto che si sta roba cos'è e
cosa sta succedendo è partita bellissima
di reply non aveva fatto lancio per caso
va bene pure di una via via via eccola
c'erano quache anno fa cenno fascino 44
eccolo eccolo sono sopra soprano capiamo
sopra c'è una che hoping affari e non ho
capito o no quello è stroncato lorenzo
ucciso
c'è ancora gente qui è lì mi riguarda ho
ucciso ok è meglio farli incazzare che
rischiare ragazzi che bellissima skin
dell'arma oh mio dio
no no ragazzi lo re guardati caschi di
quest'arma che figata previsto che
bellissima ma mi è bellissima veramente
finale ma tieni ma tranquillo no no no
pro prendi tu che io filmato orio il
crawler il provolone perché rovolon
campi infame però ci veloce 2 siete o
vicino dalla revisione studi incredibile
era un razzo pur razzo umano e senso
classiche partite due numeri nessuno
neanche se lo trovi e poi alla fine ti
uccidono decide degli santori e alla
fine siamo siamo esattamente in mezzo
alla mappa e come e nessuno si spara di
come sono e cresciuto a tutti tranne noi
giocatori
in carica hanno toccato al capitano
joe hart lane block forte e c'è un sacco
di ricordi con serio no no giuro
da lì è sono lì è di prendere gli altri
sono studiati sono la e sono la fidati
che li ho visti perché stanno bene un
approvvigionamento
sì quindi una forse dobbiamo fi tardi
facciamo li fai dei mosti dai sì però
aspettiamo che arrivino questo andando
da franco quadro è vai vai da franco
riva anch'io
franco dow i corpi hanno parlato e
quindi dobbiamo vincere perché i corpi
si sono levati al cielo
sì sì sì ma si vince li ho visti però i
corpi si sono levati al cielo te lo
giuro
e loro che ci hanno detto sì aveva detto
che si vince mi ha detto che devo andare
a mangiare che ho fame però guarda qua
sotto e questo pesce sarà passato ci
sono norme di 20 secondi fa guardate
guardate che faccio bravissimo e
figurine uscito dietro per litro e lì
dove e non come somma croci donata
povero citato uno solo questi soldi
jane si sta sparando fatto malissimo
intorno allo ping ping ping o eccolo
eccolo c'è un altro punto a destra e ora
camion la caga da dietro
quando sei in mezzo alla ulti e ti
chiedo e tu a squadre non ho due squadre
rimaste consultare d urto perché siamo
veramente pochi eccolo qua niente non ho
votato per qua bravo va da me stai calmo
stai calmo bravi ragazzi ma quant'è
forte siete forti
macheda roba da 5 kg ma nonna di ragazzi
questa altre due vittorie su ipad
ringrazio tom di essere una bestia
ringrazio pietro di essere una
adesso è una bestia ai ragazzi anche
giampiero di essere un caro amico è una
bestia anche lui effettivamente sono
tutti bestia siamo bestie
se vi è piaciuto setacciando momento mi
piace in codice limite e noi come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo dai ragazzi
[Musica]